scorn is an upcoming first person
survival horror game by ebb software
that takes visual Inspirations from the
likes of H.R Giger and one of my
personal favorites zetesla bexinski the
game releases soon so here is everything
you need to know about scorn
was started by the independent Studio
ebb software all the way back in 2014
with a failed Kickstarter however the
team continued working on the game found
a private backer and was back with a new
Kickstarter in 2017 intending to release
scorn as a two-parter game here finally
hit its goal by raising 190 000 Euros
and eventually instead of releasing the
game in two parts in 2018 ebb software
announced they would be releasing scorn
in full
scorn is focused on environmental
storytelling with a slower more
methodical gameplay approach according
to the team there are no cutscenes and
every bit of Storytelling happens in
Game as such paying attention to the
environments is key to the game in many
ways in part this will be essential to
ensure your survival as ammo in the game
is incredibly limited and you'll have to
watch for creatures or ways to close
Gates and prevent them from reaching you
in part this will help tell the story of
the game the developers have stated that
the game won't show you any sympathy if
you miss something important on your
uneasy travels whether this means you
can completely miss important weapons or
upgrades or just means you can miss
routes for survival in the moment is
unclear but it's certainly intriguing if
it's the former of the two the area
you'll be traveling is a techno-organic
hellscape where the technology of the
world fuses with Organic masses
including your own it's structured like
a dungeon and intended to be maze-like
from what we've seen so far much of your
time running through this Labyrinth will
be spent avoiding enemies while finding
organic parts of the world in order to
help you progress this could be the
game's ammo system which has your player
take ammo from a strange tissue on the
wall this could be an opening and
closing Gates which seems to be vital in
keeping enemies away and not wasting
ammo or this could be odd transports
that progress you further into the maze
while the game is a first person shooter
the guns in the game are more about
survival than a fast-paced shooter
experience ammo seems to be incredibly
limited and the player character
definitely doesn't seem to be in a hurry
when it comes to reloading there are
multiple guns we've seen which are all
organic tissue attachments that are
taken off and then applied to the base
gun we've seen a rifle a shotgun a
rocket or grenade launcher type of gun
and his strange piston style gun that
more so punches and impales enemies and
speaking of enemies we've seen slug-like
enemies that spew some sort of acid at
the player a more animal-like
quadrupedal enemy that Rams into the
player and then creatures that look like
they're probably enemies like ambling
humanoids and gigantic heads there's
also whatever this art is which could be
part of an environment or another enemy
something else I want to point out is
that this pod from an older 2020
gameplay clip reminds me of the godhead
member void from berserk and it just
terrifies me when you walk into it
though scorn has elements of shooting
and stealth the primary gameplay Loop is
composed of solving puzzle elements to
the environment is unclear how extensive
these puzzles can get but at the very
least in an 8 minute prologue video app
software released we saw one that
involved putting a misfigured creature
in an egg pod onto a similarly shaped
seat similarly many of the puzzles will
be in figuring out how to utilize the
strange biotechnology of the world from
our previewer Jordan ramay it seems like
the game will be mostly focused on
exploration figuring out these puzzles
and trying to figure out your way around
in obtuse world as far as music goes so
far it has been extremely limited with
environmental sound effects driving the
experience some trailers featured music
and there was some sort of musical
sounds near the void-like Pod but it
seems like the intent of the game is to
throw you into its World however that
world may be
after several Kickstarter delays scorm
was finally set to release October 21
2022 however just recently it was
announced that scorn is actually being
pushed up in release dates and will be
coming out this Friday October 14 2022.
scoring releases for PC on platforms
like steam epic and good old games and
will also be available for Xbox series X
slash X and Game Pass so if you have
game pass this might be the perfect way
to spend Halloween and there you have
everything you need to know about scorn
personally I'm excited to see this
unique Vision come to life especially as
a fan of this lab dexinski it looks
disgusting it looks horrifying and I
cannot wait make sure to stay tuned for
Gamespot For an upcoming review and I'll
see you next time
thank you